mathematics for machine learning
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's get certified
get ahead we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning
so today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types
and we're going to dive into linear
algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos and of course thrown in
there in the middle is going to be your
matrixes
and a few other things to go along with
all this
data in its types data denotes the
individual pieces of factual information
collected from various sources
it is stored processed and later used
for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information
a lot of tech stuff money dollar signs
numbers and then you have your
performing analytics to drive insights
and hopefully you
have a nice share your shareholders
gather it at the meeting and you're able
to explain it in something they can
understand
so we talk about data types of data we
have
in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary
always people's favorite is the
vocabulary words
okay not mine uh but let's dive into
this what we mean by nominal
nominal they are used to label various
uh
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one movie ratings etc
you can see here the salary rates if you
have ten thousand to twenty thousand
number of employees earning that rate is
150 20
000 to 30 100 and so forth
some of the terms you'll hear is bucket
this is where you have 10 different
buckets and you want to separate it into
something that makes sense into those 10
buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal
a lot of times when you get down to the
brass bones again we're talking true
false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20 k
range
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets so
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket quantitative
numerical data falls into two classes
discrete or continuous and so data with
a final set of values which can be
categorized
class strength questions answered
correctly and
runs hit and cricket a lot of times when
you see this you can think
integer and a very restricted integer
i you can only have 100 questions
on a test so you can it's very discrete
i only have 100 different values that it
can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open in
or anything like that so discrete is
very solid
simple to count set number continuous on
the other hand
continuous data can take any numerical
value within a range
so water pressure weight of a person etc
usually we start thinking about float
values where they can get phenomenally
small
and they're in what they're worth and
there's a whole series of values that
falls right between discrete
and continuous you can think of the
stock market you have
dollar amounts it's still discrete but
it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to 580.67
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete
but you start looking at it as almost
continuous because it does have such a
variance in it
now uh we talked about no we did we went
over nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data
which we'll start to get into numbers
discrete you can usually
a lot of times discrete will be put into
it could be put into true false but
usually it's not
uh so we want to address this stuff and
the first thing you want to look at is
the very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra
you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry
we have a line well let's go through
this we have a linear algebra is the
domain of mathematics concerning
linear equations and the representations
in vector
spaces and through matrixes i told you
we're going to talk about matrixes
uh so a linear equation is simply
um 2x plus 4y minus 3z
equals 10. very linear 10x plus
12.4 y equals z and now you can actually
solve these two equations by combining
them
and that's we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x
y z plot so each one is a direction
and the actual distance of like a
triangle a b
is c and then your matrix can describe
all kinds of things
i find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because
of the magnitude and the different
things they're used for and a matrix
is a chart or a you know think of a
spreadsheet but you have your rows and
your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for
making sure you have the same rows and
number of columns or a single number
there's all kinds of things that play in
that that can make matrixes confusing
but really has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in
are you adding in multiple polynomials
where you have like
uh a x squared plus b y
plus you know you start to see that can
be very confusing versus a very
straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such
primary this is what we're here to talk
about is these different math
uh mathematical computations that come
up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have
a x plus b equals c which is a one
variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c
a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about
in their addition if you have already
dived into
say neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c
z setup plus the intercept
uh which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula
is your y equals mx plus c
so you have your y equals the
m which is your slope your x value
plus c which is your y-intercept you
kind of labeled it wrong here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you
set x equal to zero y equals c
and that's that's your y-intercept right
there uh
and that's they just had a reverse value
of y when x equals zero
equals the y-intercept which is c and
your slow gradient line
which is your m so you get your y equals
two x plus three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way
this is why we always start with the
most basic one when we're solving one of
these problems
and then of course the one of the most
important takeaways is the slope
gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value in this case we went ahead and
solved this
if you have y equals 2 x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice
line graph here on the right so
matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first
column similarly a12 and it's really
pronounced a11 in this particular setup
so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two uh first row and
second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a
smaller case a for the top row or i mean
you can see where
they can go all kinds of different
directions as far as the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition
so when you think about addition you
have uh two
matrixes of two by two and you just add
each
individual number in that matrix and
then when you get to the bottom you have
in this case the solution is twelve 10
plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3 is 8 and so on
and the same thing with subtraction now
again you're counting matrixes
you want to check your dimensions of the
matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions
we're talking about the shape if the two
shapes are
equal this is what happens when you add
them together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very uh
a slightly different setup going now
if we look at our last one we're uh
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say
why you multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is 1 times 2 4
times 3
but if you look at this we get 1 times 2
plus 4 times 3
1 times 3 plus 4 times 5
6 times 2 plus 3 times 3 six times three
plus three times five
if you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we went
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at
a two variable so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b
y equals c and this is a way
to make it very quick to solve these
variables and that's why you have the
matrix and that's why you do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the
dot product of one times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes
okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving uh for equations when you're
finding the product you are just finding
one times two
keep that in mind because that does come
up i've had that come up a number of
times where i'm altering data
and i get confused as to what i'm doing
with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal
comes up all the time where you have you
still have 12 but instead of it being
12 8 it's now 12 14 8
21. you're just flipping the columns and
the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal
and you can see here we have the inverse
a to the minus 1 and ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 is now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors vector just means we have
a value and a direction and
we have down four numbers here on our
vector
uh in mathematics a one-dimensional
matrix is called a vector
uh so if you have your x plot and you
have a single value
that values along the x-axis and it's a
single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph
you might have x and you might have y
and each value denotes a direction
and then of course the actual distance
is going to be the hypothesis of that
triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means for categorizing and how close
data is together
they will compute that based on the
pythagorean theorem so you would take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual
point value and then you can compare
that point value
to another one and makes a very easy
comparison versus
comparing 50 or 60 different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span
while transformation and i gene values
the scalar values that are associated to
the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
uh
two dimensions x and y and so when you
do those two dimensions and those two
values
or whatever that value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it
and so if we take and we have a vector
a and that's a set value uh
b is um your is your you have a and b
which is your hygiene vector
2 is the ign value so we're altering
all the values by 2. that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall
if you're doing picture editing that's
one of the places this comes in but you
can see when you're transforming
uh your different information how you
transform it
is then your hygiene value and you can
see here
vector after line transit transition uh
we have 3a
a is the hygiene vector 3 is the aging
value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture
and 3 is skewing it one direction
and maybe a b is being skewed another
direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those
by the hygiene values so let's go ahead
and pull up a
demo on linear algebra and to do this
i'm going to go through my trusted
anaconda into my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new notebook called
linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy
i always import that as np or numpy
array probably the most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy
we are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10
15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15
29 and i went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read and since it's
the
last line we don't have to put the print
statement on it unless you want we can
simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get
30 24 which is what you expect 10 plus
20
15 plus 9 you could almost look at this
addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do
a dot t plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that
we now get them we now have 30 24 going
the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t and you're going to see that that
will come out the same
the 30 24 whether i transpose a and b or
transpose them both at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a
minus b and we run that
and we get minus 10 6. now remember this
is the last line in this particular
section that's right not to put the
print around it
and just like we did before we can
transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10
6 going the other way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do
a scalar multiplication and just put
down
scalar so you can remember that uh what
we're talking about here is i have
this array here u and if i go
a times u
we'll take the value two we'll multiply
it by every value in here
so 2 times 30 is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way so
in numpy uh we have what they call dot
product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of
two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the well let's walk
through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6
or our u and our v and then we're going
to go ahead and do
if we take the values
and if you remember correctly an array
like this would be
10 times 25 plus 20 times
6. we'll go ahead and print that
there we go and then we'll go ahead and
do
the np dot dot of u
comma
v and we'll find when we do this
we go and run this we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here
but for this we get a nice value for our
dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do let's
create two
complex matrixes this one
is a matrix of you know 12 10 4
6 4 31. we'll just print out a so you
can see what that looks like here's
print
a we print a out you can see that we
have
a two by 3
layer matrix for a and we can also put
together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values
we could do something like this we could
go in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with
equals a run and this kind of gives it a
nice look
uh here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2
is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and so on
and just like we did the matrix addition
we can also do
a minus b and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10
10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go eight minus ah
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
uh but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course
10 10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is minus
42 and so forth
so same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction is
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just
one number to a matrix you can also do
scalar multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array
we can also do a times b when we run
that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up a little bit of a brain teaser
is uh matrix and vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this uh
we are just doing regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array we have
a which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array
and so we can from here
do the dot a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value
is that is you could say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array first with a
and then with a second one and so it
splits it up so you have a matrix of
vector multiplication and you can mix
and match
when you get into really complicated uh
back end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data
and so you'll end up with a matrix and a
set of bolt
uh vector matrices do you want to
multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes
so if you're in the scikit looking at sk
learn where you're doing linear
regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this
and manipulate the data around so it
fits right and then you go back in
and you run it through the psi kit and
if we can do
up here where we did a matrix and vector
multiplication we can also do matrix two
matrix multiplication
and if we run this we have the two
matrixes
you can see a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose matrix which is your dot
t and so if we create a matrix a
and we do transpose it you can see how
it flips it from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5
15 25 10 20 30
rows and columns and certainly with the
math
uh this comes up a lot um it also comes
up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want
all of x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your
identity matrix uh and this one is more
definition the identity matrix
we have here one where we just did two
so it comes down as one zero
zero one one zero zero zero one zero
it creates a diagonal of one and what
that is
is when you're doing your identities you
could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one to itself
it is always 1 where
usually it's between 0 1 depending on
how well correlates
so when we're talking about identity
matrix that's what we're talking about
right here
is that you create this preset matrix
and then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do to kind
of wrap this up we'll hit you with the
most complicated
piece of this puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix and let's just go ahead and put
the um
it's a lengthy description let's go and
put the description this is straight out
of the
uh the website for
numpy so given a square matrix
a here's our square matrix a which is 2
1 0 0
1 0 1 2 1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square
it's got to be equal it's going to
return the matrix
a inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a
inverse of a with an identity shape of
a dot shaped 0. this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our
array we'll go ahead and run this and
you can see what we end up with
is we end up with an array 0.5 minus 0.5
and so forth
with our 2 1 1 going down 2 1 0 0 1
0 1 2 1. getting into
a little deep on the math understanding
when you need this is probably
really is is what's really important
when you're doing data science
versus handwriting this out and looking
up the math and handwriting all the
pieces out
you do need to know about the linear
algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up
we took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side
of what's going on here with the machine
learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already
done for you in the back end so when it
comes up you really do need to
understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
uh so we talk about calculus we're going
to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
so helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate
of change uh so suppose we plot a graph
of the speed of a car with respect to
time
so as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp
so i had to accelerate so my speed went
way up
uh stuck in traffic merged into the
traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and maybe peter's off up there so you
can look at this as
as the speed versus time i'm getting
faster and faster because i'm
continually accelerating and
if i hit the brakes you go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing
but acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it
just for that line and those two points
i want to know across
the whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate
the acceleration so the idea is
instead of i mean if you ever did took a
basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period
up into maybe 10 sections and you'd use
that and you could calculate the
acceleration between each one of those
10 sections kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller
until delta x is almost infinitesimally
small
and so we get a function of a equals a
limit as
h goes to 0 of a function of a plus h
minus a function of a
over h and that is you're computing the
slope of the line we're just computing
that slope and they're smaller and
smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral
you can see down here we have our nice
uh integral sign
looks like a giant s and that's what
that means
is that we've taken this down to as
small as we can
for that sampling so we're talking about
calculus we're finding the
area under the slope is the main process
in the integration similar small
intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of x
plus delta x where delta x approaches
almost an infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up
all the links together so we're summing
up all the accelerations from the
beginning to the end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d
of x equals a plus c
uh that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
changing w over change of time equals
change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt
it gets pretty complicated uh it really
translates into
the multivariate integration using
double integrals
and so you have the the sum of the sum
of f of x of y
of d of a equals the sum from c to d
and a to b of f of x y d x d y equals
uh the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f
x of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing
the math is usually calculus 1 calculus
2 and differential equations so you're
talking about three full length courses
to dig
into and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes
and so we're still solving a linear
expression we're still solving
y equals m x plus b but we're doing this
for infinity small
x's and then we want to sum them up
that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule
when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t
equals the change of w dz uh and
so forth that's what's going on here
that's what these means
we're basically looking for the area
under the curve which really comes
to how is the change changing
speeds going up how is that changing and
then you end up with a multiple layer
so if i have three layers of neural
networks how is the third
layer changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing
and you get the picture here that now we
have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end
of integrating these formulas and
building the script to actually build
them
so we talk about applications of
calculus it provides us the tools to
build an
accurate predictive model so it's really
behind the scenes
we want to guess at what the change of
the change or the change is
that's a little goofy i know i just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term
but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change
in the input variables so there's our
multiple variables going in there
if one variable is changing how does it
affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local
and global maxima and this is really big
we're going gonna actually gonna have a
whole section here on gradient descent
because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there
but gradient descent is one of the most
key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error hard to read
there
and i want to make the error as low as
possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace
here and it goes hey this is still going
down it goes
here and then goes back over here and
then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best
output of it that's simply minus the
value
uh so if you're looking for where the
peak is this
is the same as a negative for where the
valley is
looking for that valley that's all that
is this is a way of finding it
so the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting's done
i actually ended up putting together one
of these a while back is
when i didn't know about sidekick and i
was just starting
boys a long while back and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're gonna note and this
is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models
you're going to find these things are
stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind your model that you're
working
with is very generic so whatever you use
to minimize it
the first question is where do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we arbitrarily picked five learning
rate is uh how many bars to skip
going one way or the other i'm in fact
i'm going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
um if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function 2 times x plus
5
keep it simple so that's a function
we're going to work with
so if i'm dealing with increments of
1000.1
is going to be a very long time and if
i'm
dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm
so again very specific to what you're
working on
if you're working with money and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations
we want something to cut out at a
certain point usually that's built into
a lot of
minimization functions and then here's
our actual
uh formula we're going to be working
with and then we come in we go
while previous step size is greater than
precision and iters is less than max
and max it errs say that
10 times fast um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or 10
000
running that's actually pretty high we
almost never do max iterations more than
like 100 or 200
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with
uh so we have our previous equals our
current that way we can track time wise
the current now equals the current minus
the rate times
the formula of our previous x so now
we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current
previous so we're looking for the change
in
x errors equals iterations plus one
that's so we know to stop if we get too
far and then we're just going to print
the local
minimum occurs at x on here
and if we go ahead and run this uh you
can see right here it gets down to this
point
and it says hey local minimum
is minus 3.322 for this particular
series we created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus five
now when i'm running this stuff you'll
see this come up a lot
in with the sk learn kit and
one of the nice reasons of breaking this
down the way we did
is i could go over those top pieces uh
those top pieces are
everything when you start looking at
these minimization tool kits
in built-in code and so from
we'll just do it's actually docs
dot scipy.org
and we're looking at the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here it could be there's all kinds of
things that could be on there and
there's a number of methods to solve
this as far as how they shrink down
uh and your x naught there's your
there's your start value
so your function your start value um
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point
you want to start with something that
you already know is mostly the answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
uh so statistics well i guess it's all
relative
it's definitely not an edel class so a
bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful so
we have from end to end where does it
come from is it valid what does it mean
how do we organize it um how do we
analyze it
and then you gotta take those analysis
and interpret it into something that
uh people can use kind of reduce it to
understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies there is
a lot of terminologies depending on what
domain you're working in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with viruses
and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people that you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling
statistics uh to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that
that can be a big deal you know we have
these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick
up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed so that's your population all
the objects
it's easy to see it with people because
we have our population
enlarged but in the case of the sewer
fans we're talking about how
the fan units that's the population of
fans that we're working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied
you don't want to do them all because
then you don't have a if you come up
with a conclusion for everyone
you don't have a way of testing it so
you take a sample uh sometimes you don't
have a choice you can only take a sample
of what's going on
you can't study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object
in a population types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach
selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than
random selection it has to do with
convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
that says biased
so you gotta be very careful on that so
probabilistic sampling uh when we talk
about a random sampling we select random
size samples from each group or category
so we it's as random as you can get uh
we talk about
systematic sampling we're selecting
random size
samples from each group or category with
a fixed periodic
interval uh so we kind of split it up
this would be like a time
set up or different categories and you
might ask your question
what is a category or a group if you
look at
i'm going to go back a window let's say
we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh
and why i say separated i don't mean
separated from their
place where they live i mean as far as
the analysis we want to look at the
different groups
and make sure they're all represented so
if we had like an
eighty percent uh of a group that is uh
say hispanic and or indian and
also in that same area we have 20
percent 20 percent who
are let's call our expatriates they left
america and they're nice and
your caucasian group we might want to
sample
a group that is representative of both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling
and we're talking about groups those are
the groups we're talking about and it
brings us to stratified sampling
selecting approximately equal size
samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories
and give us an insight into the
different cultures and how that might
affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with as
far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just a little bit
more we'd have selecting 25 employees
from a company of 250 employees randomly
don't care anything about them what
groups are in which office they're in
nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique
employees and a company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch
the category could depend on what you're
studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also
used to generate a lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics uh we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential
statistics there are so many different
terms and statistics to break it up
uh so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup so we're talking about descriptive
and inferential
uh statistics the base of the word
describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like
with inferential statistics we're going
to take that from the small population
to a large population
so if you're working with a drug company
you might look at the data and say
these people were helped by this drug
they did uh 80 percent better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people
so that's where you get your inferential
so we are
predicting how it's going to affect the
greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic
features of data and form the basis of
quantitative analysis of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean
median and mode and then we have a
measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how the data difference differences you
know
what's the max min range all that stuff
is your spread
and anything that's just a single number
is usually your central
uh tendencies measure of central
tendencies so we talk about the mean
it is the average of the set of values
considered what is the average
outcome of whatever's going on and then
your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those
outliers out where the median would
by separating the high from the low
might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why
is the average so much higher than the
median well it's because you have some
outliers or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the
most common income like in the u.s was
1.24 000 a year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that
way up so the average person is not
making that kind of money
and then you look at the median income
and you're like well the median income
is
a little bit closer to the average so it
does create a very interesting
way of looking at the data again these
are all
uh central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students
and as we talked about the median we
have
0 through 10 and we take half the
numbers and put them on one side of the
line half the numbers on the other side
of the line
uh we end up with five in the middle and
then the mode what mark was scored by
most of the students
in a test in a simple case where most
people scored like an 82 percent and got
certain
problems wrong easy to figure out uh not
so easy
when you have different areas where like
you have like the um
oh let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group that scores that makes
thirty thousand
and a slightly bigger group that makes
twenty six thousand so what do you put
down for the mode
uh certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh
range what's the difference between the
highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
scored between 60 and 100
somebody got 100 or maybe 60 to 90
percent
it was so hard that a lot of people
could not get a hundred percent
you have your inter-quartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four equal parts very common thing
to do
as part of all the basic packages
whether you're working
in data frames with pandas
whether you're working in scala whether
you're working in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max
and then it'll have your interquartile
range how does it look like in each
quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean
and therefore from every other number in
the set
so you have like how much turbulence is
going on in this data and then the
standard deviation
it is to measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
gra
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
uh so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread
uh marks of a student out of a hundred
uh we have here from 50 to 63 or
50 to 90. so the range maximum marks
minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45.
and then we have the interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is
and then there's the first quarter the
second quarter
and the third quarter based on splitting
it apart by those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
uh so here's our our you know
calculating the average there
we end up approximately 66 for the
average
and then we look at that the variance
once we know the means we can do
equals the marks minus the mean squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure it's
you don't have like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an
error as far as one's negative one's
positive one's a little higher one's a
little lower
so you always see the squared value and
over the total observations
and so the standard deviation equals the
square root of the variance which is
approximately
16. and if you were looking at a
predictable model you would be looking
at the
deviation based on the error how much
error does it have
and that's again really important to
know if your if your prediction is
predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks
like in python code so you can get some
little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupiter notebook and python
now almost all of this you can do in
numpy last time we worked
in numpy this time we're going to go
ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns
let's just go ahead and do a print
df.head
and run that and you can see we have
the name jane michael william rosie
hannah sat in their salaries on here
and of course instead of having to do
all those hand calculations and add
everything together and divide by the
total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go and do this
print df pick our column salary because
we want to find the means of that color
e
we want to find the means of that column
uh and we go and print this out and you
can see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
uh and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are the use of
two different words
uh there can be in some computation
slight differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops let's put a
median here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better
we can see the median is 54 000. so the
halfway mark
is significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here makes
189
000. darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge
and so is what is the meaning behind
that when you're studying a populist and
looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most
common income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode and you can see
here with the mode
it's at 50 000. so this is this is very
telling that most people are making 50
000
the middle point is at 54 000 so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common
income is weight is below the median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics
when you're analyzing the economy in
different people's income
is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was
you might start asking questions at that
point why aren't you talking about the
median income
why aren't you talking about the mode
the most common income
what are you hiding and if you're doing
these analysis you should be looking at
these saying hey
why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any
analysis it's important to find out the
minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh um
dot min it'll pull up your minimum and
then dot max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as um
translating it and knowing which you
know put the your
lowest value which your highest value is
here um
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on note
mode uh note that it puts mode
zero like i said there's a couple
different ways you can compute the mode
although the standard one is pretty good
we can of course do the range
which is your max minus your min so now
we have a range of 149
000 between the upper end and the lower
end
and you might want to be looking up the
individual values on all of these
but it turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas and so in pandas we
can actually do df salary describe
and if we do this you can see we have
that there's seven
uh setups here's our mean um our
standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which should just be a dot
std and you gotta be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information
and then split it up and depending on
what you need now if i just walked in
and gave you this information
in a meeting at some point you would
just kind of
fall asleep that's what i would do
anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here
and we'll go ahead and put it into a
histogram and plot that graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here
so we do our matplot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing
a lot of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library piplot is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print df that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title
salary distribution color gray
uh plot ax v line salary the mean value
so we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style dash this is
just all making it pretty
uh what color dashed line line width of
2
that kind of thing and the median and
let's go ahead and run this just so you
can see we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
um so here's the data here's our our
data frame
print it out so you can see it with the
salaries we'll look at the salary
distribution
and just look at this the way the salary
is distributed
you have our in this case we did let's
see we had red
for the median we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money
here's the average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home
all it does is tell you how much money
is in this you know
what the average salary is so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is
that it's very easy to plot
an ax v line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated
keeping it simple is pretty
straightforward i look at this and i can
see we have
a major outlier out here we can
definitely do a histogram and stuff like
that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away
is that we can do a basic describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
being able to it doesn't have the print
on there so it's only going to print
the last one which happens to be the
mean you can very easily reference any
one of these
and then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics you
can come through and pull
any one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here
so now we've had a chance to describe
our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or
inferences from data and you can see
here we have a
nice little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say
and then you ask just a random person
who comes out of the movie who hasn't
been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't
say so that's real basics of what we're
talking about is you're going to infer
that the next person is going to follow
these statistics
so let's look at point estimation uh it
is a process of finding an approximate
value for a populations parameter
like mean or average from random samples
of the population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's a protected there's our small
group up here where we've selected them
we run medical trials on them and then
the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary
coveted virus in the middle of one and
let's take a look at the applications of
inferential statistics very
central is what they call hypotheses
testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that
and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is used to measure
the plausibility of a hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorem's
theory hypothesis uh
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory is the same as hypothesis
where theorem is a scientific uh
statement that is something that has
been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate
so hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven
gravity is a theory so if you want to
debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about
why the economy is collapsing in your
area
that is a philosophical debate very
important
i've heard people mix those up and it is
a pet peeve of mine
when we talk about hypotheses testing
the steps involved in hypotheses testing
is first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test
and we make a decision and so when
you're talking about hypothesis you're
usually trying to
disprove it if you can't disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case uh let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves
they did so by making four chits which
has their names on it and the name that
gets picked
up has to do the cleaning for that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it
so here's our four people nick rob
emilia emilia
and summer now rick emilia and summer
are asking us to decide whether rob has
done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day
second day third day and so on till 12
days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day
i.e his turn never comes up then
definitely he has done some mischief
while making the chits so the
probability of rob not doing work on day
one
is uh three out of four there's a point
75 chance that he didn't do work
uh two days three-fourths times
three-fourths equals 0.56
three days you have three-fourths
three-fourths three-fourths which equals
0.42
when you get to day 12 it's 0.032 which
is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when on day 12
he still hasn't gotten the job cleaning
the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis a general
statement that states that there is
no relationship between two measured
phenomenon or no
association among the groups alternative
hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening
a new theory is preferred instead of an
old one
and so the two hypotheses go hand in
hand uh
so your null this is always interesting
in and when talking about data science
and the math behind it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation
null hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other
where the alternative hypothesis says
hey we found a relation this is what it
is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question
is true and the t value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error
the greater the magnitude of t the
greater the evidence against the null
hypothesis
and you can look at the t values being
specific to the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value
and you're looking for what they call
the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper
let's assume that a new drug is
developed with the goal of lowering the
blood pressure more than the existing
drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation
and the new drug is not doing its job
the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug
uh yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for a 0.05 or
5 percent
and the t value comparing all the
positive test results and finding means
of different samples in order to test
hypothesis
so this is specific to the test how what
percentage of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure
our true values of observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of
food do you buy for your per year for
your dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food
hence we can say that we have a
confidence interval of 2
300 where 95 percent of our values lie
in that spread data spread and this the
graph really helps a lot so you can
start seeing what you're
looking at here where you have the 95
percent you have your peak
in this case it's a normal distribution
so you have a nice bell curve equal on
both sides it's not asymmetrical
and 95 of all the values lie within a
very small range and then you have your
outliers the 2.5 percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into
probability so you have your hypothesis
once you've generated your hypothesis we
want to know the probability of
something occurring
probability is a measure of the
likelihood of an event to occur
any event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
so any event cannot be predicted with
total certainty can only be predicted as
a likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under
one in trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them so we talk about
a random variable
a random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena
so uh we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really can't know because
it's very random
how many times a red ball is picked from
a bag of balls if there's equal number
of red balls and blue balls and green
balls in there
how many times the sum of digits on two
dice
results are five each
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your
paradigms
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice
we have a random variable outcome equals
y you can take values
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice for roll five let's go ahead
and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different
options you have four of those random
rolls can be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
you can see that we have four out of 36
chance every time you roll
the dice that you're gonna roll a total
of five you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means
but you could think of that at what
point if someone never rolls a five or
they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that
but let's just consider this is one of
the cases is rolling two dice and
gambling
there's also binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success
or failure as an outcome in an
experiment or trial that is repeated
multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial
so passing or failing an exam winning or
losing a game
and getting either head or tails so if
you ever see binomial distribution it's
based on
a true false kind of setup you win or
lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches
and we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or
0.75 that means that each game they have
a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25
or 0.25 clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals
1. so that accounts for 100 of the game
probability for getting k
wins in in matches is calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play
how many wins in those five games should
i get what's a percentage on those
and the probability for getting k wins
and in matches
is calculated by p x equals k equals
nc k p to the k q to the n
minus k here p is the probability of
success
and q is the probability of failure and
so we can do total games of
n equals 5 where k equals 0 1 2
3 4 5 p which is the chance of winning
is 0.75
q the chance of losing equals 1 minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25
the probability that barcelona will lose
all of the matches can then
just plug in the numbers and we end up
with a 0.0009765625
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches
probability that barcelona will win at
least two matches
is 0.0878 and of course we can go on to
the probability that barcelona will win
three matches
the 0.26 and of course four matches
and so on and it's always nice to take
this information
and let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three
x equals four x equals five and we end
up with the
p equals point two six four plus point
three nine five plus two three seven
which equals point eight nine
in reality the probability of barcelona
winning the series is much higher than
0.75
and it's always nice to uh put out a
nice graph so you can actually see
the number of wins to the probability
and how that pans out
with our binomial case continuing in our
important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends
on the mean value and this is some very
important things
so much of the data we look at and when
you start looking at probabilities
almost always has a normalized look like
the graph in the middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening off to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed
it's really important to take a closer
look at that mostly you end up with a
normalized set of data but you got to
also be aware that sometimes it's a
skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon
the standard deviation so you can see
down here the standard deviation is
really large it kind of squishes it out
and if the standard deviation is small
then most of your data is going to hit
right there in the middle you can have a
nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that
fits certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're
if you have a really high standard
deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target
and set to become a millionaire which
leads us to the z-score
z-score tells you how far from the mean
a data point
is it is measured in terms of standard
deviations from the mean
around 68 of the results are found
between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there
we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u
it just means the mean uh and then the
sigma is the standard deviation and
that's the o with the little arrow off
to the right or the little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it
so mu minus two sigma is your
uh 95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem this goes back to
the skew
if you remember we were looking at the
skew values on this previous
slide have left skewed normalized and
right skewed when we're talking about it
being skewed or not skewed
the distribution of the sample means
will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed
if you take large random samples from
the population
with the mean mu and the standard
deviation
sigma with replacement and you can see
here
of course we have our mu minus two sigma
and the spread down here
the mean the median and the mode and so
when you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value
if you do that's a flag that something's
wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it
and if we're going to do all this we got
to jump into conditional
probability the conditional probability
of an event a
is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event to be
has already occurred
and you'll see this as bayes theorem
b-a-y-e-s
base and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets
a b this is the probability of a being
true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true
so p b of a probability of a
being true divided by the probability of
b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this
this is such an important formula and
it's really it's not
if you actually do the math you could
just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math
but it works with probabilities which
makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine
different studies going on in different
areas different people have done the
studies they brought them together
if we look at today's covered virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the us
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science
and understanding where your data is
coming from and how you're going to
combine
different studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease
due to smoking this is kind of
interesting the way they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated
suffered lung disease so we have kind of
a generic
medical report they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them
smoke so we have 10 percent that are
lung disease
and 15 of the patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke
even when they had lung disease uh not
the brightest
choice um but you know it is an
addiction so it can be really difficult
to kick
and so we can look at the probability of
a uh
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes
is 15 uh
and the probability of b if b then
a the probability of a patient smokes
even though they have
lung disease is five percent and
probability of a
is b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and then when you put the formulas
together you get a nice solution here
you get
the probability of a of b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a
3.33 chance hence there is a 3.33
chance that a person who smokes will get
a lung disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code
i'm always my favorite roll up the
sleeves keep in mind
we're going to be doing this um kind of
like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set
so we're going to create a set with
curly braces this means that
our set has only unique
values so you have a list you have your
tuples which
can never change and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four
out so it's only unique values and if
you use
dictionaries quick reminder
this should look familiar because it is
a dictionary
we have a value and that value is
assigned to
or that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven we can also
take a list a regular setup and i'm
going to go ahead and just throw in
another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if i
take my list one two three four
four and i convert it to a set
and here it is my set from list equals
set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set uh
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set
six is not in the set and so forth if we
run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one
six is in the set six is not in the set
so not in my set you can also
use this with the list we could have
just used three five
seven and it would have the same
response on there
is three and usually do if three is in
but three in my set is still works on
just a regular list and we'll go ahead
and do a little iteration
we're going to do kind of the dice one
remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the iteration tool
and import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
they can only have one
value for each one that's why they put
it in a set and if you remember from
range it is up to seven so this is going
to be one two three four
five six it will not include the seven
and the same thing for our dice b
and then we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a list
which is the product of a
and b so what's uh a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice
where dice a is one two three one to six
and dice b is one to six and you can see
one to one
one to two one to three and so forth you
remember we had a slide on this earlier
where we talked about the different all
the different outcomes of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do
in dice equals two divi dice faces one
two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space
where we have a set which is the product
of the dice faces
repeat equals in dice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here
and print them all out like we had
before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome
and equals so the event space
is creating a sequence and as you can
see here when we print it out
it stacks them versus going through and
putting them in a nice line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means
it's just gonna it's not gonna hit the
return going down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length uh we'll print it
twice and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space
of x y equals outcome if
x plus y remainder 3. so we're going to
divide by 3 and look at the remainder
and it equals 0
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set
not necessary because we know it's not
going to be repeating itself but just in
case we'll go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
uh multiples of three one plus two is
three
five plus four is nine which divided by
three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length of our
f outcome so we can see what that looks
like
there we go and of course i did forget
to add the print in the middle because
we're looping through and putting an end
on the
on the setup on there so we're going to
put the print in there and if i run this
you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length of our
favorable outcome over the length of the
event space
if we print it out let me put that in
there probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with the 0.3333
chance that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of 3
is 0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
you can see we just have a huge amount
of choices
so just goes on and on down here and we
can look at
the length of the event space
and we have over 7 76
choices that's a lot of choices and if
we want to ask the question like we did
above
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not
a multiple of three we can go through
all of these different options
and then you can see here d1 d2 d3 d4 d5
equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not
we can just append that on here and then
we can look at that
uh favorable outcome we'll go ahead and
set that and we'll just
take a look at this what's our length of
our
favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
776
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of three and so we're
just going to divide those two numbers
and you can see here we get
point one one six two five five or
eleven point six two percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not
really complicated math right here on
probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to
come up with with the solution you're
looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data
for which the true values are known and
so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted and the actual and we have
a negative
uh false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative
and you can think of this as your
predicted
model what does that mean that means if
you divided your data
and you used two-third of this to create
the model you might then test it against
an actual case for the last third to see
how well it comes out how many times was
it
true positive versus a false positive it
gave a false positive response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal
you don't want to give a false positive
so you might adjust your model
accordingly so you don't have a false
positive say with a covavirus test
it'd be better to have a false negative
and they go back and get retested
than to have 30 false positives where
then the test is pretty much invalid so
in a use case
like cancer prediction let's consider an
example where a cancer prediction model
is put to the test for its accuracy and
precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted uh whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have
a false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do
so that would be something you'd really
be looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of
pieces of data that come in there's a
real famous case study where they have
the imagery and all the measurements
they take and there's about 36 different
measurements they take and then if you
run the a basic model
you want to know just how accurate it is
how many negative
results do you have that are either
telling people they have cancer that
don't or telling people that don't have
cancer that they do
and then we can take these numbers and
we can feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the true
negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate
versus what were wrong we talked about
precision is a metric to measure how
many of the correctly predicted cases
are actually turned out to be
positive uh so we have a precision
on true positive again if you're talking
about
like covid testing with the viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this
true that to be the center point where
you might have the opposite if you're
dealing with
a cancer where you want no false
negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
uh so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a demo
on the naive bayes classifier
before i get too far into a
naive bayes classifier because we're
going to pull it from the sklearn
or the site kit let's go ahead
kind of an interesting page here for
classifiers when you go into the sk
learn kit
there's a lot of ways to do
classification and i'll just zoom up in
here so you can
see some of the titles there's
everything from the nearest neighbor
linear but we're going to be focusing on
the naive bayes
over here and this is just a sample data
set that they put together and you can
see how
some of these have a very different
output the naive bayes remember is set
up as
probably the most simplified uh
calculator or
set of predictions out there and so what
we've been talking about with the true
false and stuff like that where there's
a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction
and so that's what we're using is a
naive bayes classifier
versus many of the other classifiers
that are out there
for this we're going to use uh the
social network
ads it's a little data set on here and
let me go and just open that up
the file here we go it has user id
gender age estimated salary uh purchased
and so we have you can see the user id
mail
19. estimated salary 19
000 and purchased zero so it's either
going to make a purchase or not
so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of
a simple naive bayes classifier kind of
setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as
np nice to have a good visual
of our data so we'll put in our matplot
library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be
we're going to read it from the social
network ads.csv
then we're going to print the head just
so you can see it again even though i
showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
2 3 values and y is going to be the 4
column 4. let me just run this it's a
little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at 0 1
2 as age and estimated salary so
2 3 and that's what i location just
means
that we're looking at the number versus
a regular location a regular location
you'd actually say
age and estimated salary and then column
four is did they make a purchase
they purchased something so those are
the three columns we're going to be
looking at when we do this and we've
gone ahead and imported these and
imported the data so now our data set is
all set with this information in it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
data up so we need our from the sk learn
model selection
we can import train test split
this does a nice job we can set the
random state so randomly picks the data
and we're just going to take uh 25
percent of it's going to go into the
test
our x test and our y test and the 75
will go to x train and y train that way
once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our
prediction the
next step in pre-processing our data is
to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this is start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other
modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of
minus 1 and 1 or someplace in the
middle ground there this way if you have
any huge set
you don't have this huge um setup if we
go back up to here where salary
the salary is 20 000 versus age
35. well there's a good chance with a
lot of the back end math
that 20 000 will skew the results and
the estimated salary will have a higher
impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our
naive bayes model um and then we're
going to go ahead and import the
gaussian
naive bayes and
the gaussian is is the most basic one
that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the
sk learn kit
they have a number of different ones you
can pull in there there's a
bernoulli i don't know i've never used
that one categorical
complement and here's our gaussian so
there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they
when they're pulling this in and one of
the nice things about the gaussian if
you go to their website
um to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all i
want you
once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it
as far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier
we're going to equal the gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data
and our training solution so x train y
train
and we'll go ahead and run this uh it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y
predict equals the classifier.predict x
test
so here we fit the data and now we're
going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from the sk learn matrix metrics you
can import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y test and
the y predict
so we have our actual and we have our
predicted value
and you can see from here this is the
chart we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive
false negative true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65
3 7 25
and in this particular prediction we had
65
or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase
and we guessed three wrong and then we
had 25 we predicted would not purchase
and seven of them did so there's our our
confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
you would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix so let's go ahead and visualize
the results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine is going
to throw an error because
this is being because of the way the
setup is
i have a newer version on here than when
they put together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y
train and then we'll create our x1 x2
and we'll put that into a grid uh and we
set our x set
minimum stop and our x at max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01
this is going to give us a nice line is
what that's doing
and we're going to plot the contour plot
the x limit
plot the y limit and put the scatter
plot in there
let's go ahead and run this to be honest
when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that there's so many different ways to
put this code together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to
pull up the graph and then go back up
and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking
at the data is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that
that's defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green
and you can see that some of the green
drops fall into the red area and some of
the red dots fall into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent
uh we couldn't do that and so we're
looking at our different
data coming down uh we can kind of
arrange our x1 x2 so we have a nice plot
going on
and we're going to create the contour
that's that nice line that's drawn down
the middle on here with the red green
um that's where that's what this is
doing right here with the reshape
and notice that we had to uh do the dot
t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module you end up
with pairs
you know x x1 x2 x1 x2
next row and so forth you have to flip
it so it's all one row you have all your
x1's and all your x2s
so this is what we're kind of looking
for right here on this setup
and then the scatter plot is of course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points
that puts these nice little dots on to
our setup on here
and we have our estimated salary and our
h and then of course the dots are did
they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train
which seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25 percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set
and it if you look at the two graphs
next to each other this one obviously
has
75 percent of the data so it's going to
show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by
age and income they're going to make a
purchase or not
but that said it still is pretty clear
it's pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers
and so we're going to do from sklearn
we're going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it pulls in pretty good
as far as
how accurate it is you could say it's
going to be about 90 percent
is going to guess correctly that it that
they're not going to purchase
and we had an 89 chance that they are
going to purchase
um and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need
and if you forgot the exact definition
of accuracy
it is the true positive true negative
over
all of the different setups precision is
your true
positive over all positives true and
false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus false
negative and we can just real quick flip
back there
so you can see those numbers on here
here's our precision
here's our recall and here's our
accuracy on this
thank you for joining us for mathematics
for machine learning
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here